sur les bords du gange des dizaines de
corps échoués
des images qui révèle à elle seule
l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire que
traversé l'inde
faute de pouvoir brûler les corps comme
le veut la tradition des familles
endeuillées les jette dans le fleuve
nous avons dit à l'administration qu'en
raison d'un manque de bois les morts
sont enterrés dans l'eau les corps
d'environ 12 à 13 villages ont été
enterrés dans l'eau depuis ce mardi
l'inde a passé la barre des 250 mille
morts duo kobe 19
un chiffre conséquent mais bien loin du
bilan réel
selon de nombreux experts les décès sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que ce que nos
données officielles révèlent même trois
à quatre fois plus ce serait une
sous-estimation les hôpitaux sont
saturés
plus aucun lit n'est disponible le pays
doit faire face à une pénurie d'oxygène
et de médicaments on ne peut obtenir des
médicaments que sur le marché noir
un jour j'ai acheté une dose pour
vingt-huit mille roupies
le lendemain j'ai acheté trois autres
doses pour le même prix et la troisième
fois j'ai dû payer deux mille roupies de
plus dépassé par le nombre croissant de
morts
les cimetières et crématoriums sont
submergés partout dans le pays les
bûcher funéraire se multiplient avant on
avait jusqu'à dix corps par jour
maintenant c'est plutôt entre 40 et 50
après les grandes villes le virus semble
touché l'arrière pays rural de l'inde
là où vivent les deux tiers de la
population